la commission sur l'état d'urgence et
maintenant ouverte la commission rouleau
a replonger l'assistance au cœur du
convoi de camionnette
des enregistrements des klaxons ont été
présentés les témoins ont des cris un
univers chaotique sur mes perturbé rue
bloqué odeur de diesel et feu à ciel
ouvert dans leur quartier sans
malvoyante s'est senti prisonnières chez
elle forcer d'appeler un ami à la
rescousse
peux-tu venir me chercher et me sortir
d'ici
le simple fait de porter un masque dans
la rue faisait de vous une cible
d'intimidation c'était lui municipal a
reçu des centaines de courriels de
résidents terrorisés
[Musique]
par les autorités en l'absence de
policiers dans leur quartier viennent
formation
les communications des élus avec le
service de police était difficile
l'arrivée du convoi a-t-elle été prise
au sérieux pourquoi on peut pas fermer
les rues puis on a eu plusieurs
différentes réponses cette représentante
de la communauté d'affaires se souvient
d'un appel inquiétant avec l'ancien chef
de police d'Ottawa Peter slowly
des anecdotes pour de quoi surprendre
comme un magasin grande surface qui
rapportait avoir écoulé tout son
inventaire de couteau et de répulsif à
ours lors de la troisième fin de semaine
de manifestation
semble avoir été dépassés par les
événements ils auront à répondre aux
nombreuses questions soulevées lors de
ses premiers témoignages pourquoi la
police d'Ottawa a-t-elle laissée entrer
les camions dans la ville l'ampleur de
la contestation semble avoir été
sous-estimée les policiers semblaient
dépassés peu présents dans certains
quartiers résidentiels selon ce qu'on a
entendu aujourd'hui le témoignage de
responsable policier la semaine
prochaine sera centrale parce qu'il nous
permettra peut-être de comprendre
pourquoi les autorités semblent avoir
été prise de cours c'est important parce
que cette période initiale a été
déterminante pour la suite de la crise
dans la capitale et constitue un pas
dans la marche qui a mené à l'adoption
par le gouvernement fédéral de
l'évocation de la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence il y a une conseillère
municipale aujourd'hui qui a dit qu'elle
était d'accord avec l'invocation des
pouvoirs d'urgence par le gouvernement
fédéral parce qu'elle était désespérée
elle voulait que sa ville soit libérée
mais je vous rappelle que de manière
plus large le gouvernement Trudeau
pendant cette commission devra expliquer
en quoi il était confronté à une crise
nationale pas seulement locale merci
beaucoup Louis au revoir